-Well, I want to
talk about another thing
that happened this year --
recently, about a month ago,
where I thought you might be too
jittery, but you kept your cool.
We went and saw
Bruce Springsteen on Broadway.
-Bruce Springsteen, "The Boss."
-Yeah.
-The best. The best.
-It was a birthday present.
-And then, afterwards, we got to
say hi to Bruce Springsteen.
-And I don't know why I thought
that that wouldn't happen,
but I didn't think
it would happen.
-Well, you're supposed to not
think it's gonna happen.
It's a surprise.
-But, sometimes --
-That's where she's at
in her life right now.
-Yeah.
-If she didn't meet him,
it might have been
like, "Oh, bummer."
-Yeah.
-But you did
and you took a picture.
And, Dad, I have a question,
'cause I'm gonna show
the picture of
Mom and Bruce Springsteen.
Has Mom ever
looked that happy with you?
-Can I hold that up a second?
-Yeah, yeah. Sure.
-I got to look closer.
No.
-Yeah.
And I have to say,
it was really nice,
'cause I wasn't gonna
ask for a picture,
and you were not gonna
ask for a picture.
And we said hello
and we were walking out,
and his beautiful, talented
wife, Patti Scialfa, said,
"Bruce, you have to take
a picture with Seth's mom."
-Right.
-And then you repaid her
by getting real handsy
with Bruce Springsteen
right here.
-And there's
another picture, though,
where he's
actually smooching me.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-I don't know if I saw that one.
-At your wedding, you guys --
for the, like, mother-son dance,
sang, like, an unusual song.
-Our first dance --
Well, not our first dance.
-"She's the --"
-No, "For You."
-"For You."
"I came for you."
-Yeah. And it was nice.
And it's not a very common
first-dance song.
-No. It was like
a jitterbug dance,
and people didn't expect that.
-No. Well, there was a lot that
they didn't
expect from our wedding.
So, another thing
I want to say --
we showed a video of Ashe,
and, a couple years ago
on this show,
we announced that
we were having Ashe.
And, so, I want to take
this opportunity now --
You guys obviously know.
But my wife and I are
expecting a second baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And...very excited.
Thank you. Very excited.
-So, I have to say --
I get the phone call,
and my Seth
is sometimes a crier.
-Yeah. Quite a bit, quite a bit.
-Okay. So, he's
crying on the phone
and he can't catch his breath.
He's, like, sobbing.
And I said, "What?
What happened? Are you okay?"
And he said, "No, no.
It's wonderful news.
It's wonderful news."
I said, "What is it?"
And he said, "Well,
we're gonna have another baby."
I said, "That's fabulous.
Why are you crying?"
He said,
"Because, for over a month,
I've had to pretend that
I don't care what sex it is,
and I do care.
I want a little boy
so we can be Sufi and Posh.
-That's true.
I really wanted
a brother for my son
because I was
so lucky to have one.
-Yeah. They've always been
the best of friends.
Two years apart,
and that's exactly what
Ashe and Albert
are gonna be, right?
-Well, now, okay, so, you...
[ Laughter ]
'Cause we have not
decided on a name.
But, Dad, explain why you
feel so strongly about Albert.
-Well, for the old sweats that
have been here every year,
we've had five sheepdogs,
and they're all named Albert.
We have Albert V.
And I really love the dog.
And I always wonder
what it would sound like
if it could talk.
But I never hear, like, a voice,
like, on a cartoon or a movie
or a child that, "That's what
Albert would sound like."
So I figure if they name
the kid Albert, eventually,
he'll start to talk, and
I'll say, "Oh, yeah, that's it."
And this is a
little bit sad on Thanksgiving,
but the kid's gonna
outlive the dog.
-Yeah.
-And so if I have a --
It's like Pinocchio.
You know, he becomes a real --
The dog becomes a real boy,
and everything works out.
-Yeah.
-It's great.
-That's great.
You know my wife.
Do you think this
would be a tough sell?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, no. Wait.
We have one advantage.
She is big on the A's, so I know
it's gonna be an "A" name.
-Yeah.
-Right.
-Can I tell you
that the fact it's been
five of our dogs's names
has eliminated it from --
-You can tell us that,
but it doesn't mean
we have to stop hoping for it.
-That's true.
And, by the way,
I have another son.
Who knows, someday,
if that doesn't work out?
-Hypothetically,
if you had a child,
would Albert be eliminated
as a possibility?
-Albert was my name in
her French class.
-That's right.
-Yeah.
I think it's a great name.
-All right.
-It is a great name.
-Hillary's voting for Bruce,
by the way.